(soft music)
- [Narrator] This August, Apple became
the most valuable publicly
traded company in the world.
Overtaking Aramco as its market
cap soared past $2 trillion
for the first time ever.
- And that is a $2 trillion milestone.
- Shares of the company increased
nearly 60% this year.
I mean, it really is history.
- [Narrator] But the
company's road to $2 trillion,
hasn't been a straight climb.
After founder, Steve
Jobs passed away in 2011,
many investors doubted that
his successor, Tim Cook
could fill his shoes and
propel the company forward.
- Really a trillion dollar market cap
wasn't part of the discussion back then.
It was much more about whether Tim Cook
could even sustain the level
of success that they'd had.
- [Narrator] But amidst lawsuits,
regulatory investigations,
and an ongoing trade war,
Apple's shares have surged.
This is how Apple became
the most valuable publicly
traded company in the world.
- Introducing Apple II, the
easy to operate home computer.
- [Narrator] Apple first
launched its Apple II
home computer in 1977,
revolutionizing the industry in the world.
But to follow its rise to the very top,
a good place to start is August, 2018.
When Apple reached its
$1 trillion market cap,
for the first time ever
surpassing other tech giants
by billions of dollars.
- Apple is now as valuable
as the four biggest US banks combined.
And if you'd put $10, 000 in Apple in 1980
today, you'd be a millionaire.
- [Narrator] The company was coming off
one of its strongest years
since the death of Steve Jobs.
- Apple had had some
stumbles up through 2016
and there were doubts
about Tim Cook's leadership
and the company's products prospects
in the China market.
Things started to stabilize really
later that year and in 2017
and by 2018, I think
people had a sense that
the company was really clicking again.
The iPhone 10 had come out
and you saw the stock just continued
to rise and rise and rise
and then in the middle of the 2018,
it kind of shot out to
get over the milestone.
- [Narrator] In July,
2018, the company reported
its best third quarter ever.
Its flagship iPhones
remained widely popular
and sales from the app
store and other services
had hit all time highs,
but this wasn't going to last.
About a month later,
Apple released a new suite of iPhones,
which included it's most
expensive model yet.
(audience applauds)
- This is iPhone 10S.
It is the most advanced
we've ever created.
- They were riding high in 2018,
going into the launch of the
new phones later that year,
they were sounding very confident
that those phones would succeed.
- [Narrator] But things
didn't go as expected.
In January, 2019,
Apple announced it had missed
its expectation for iPhone sales.
This had a lot to do with
the ongoing trade war
between the US and China.
- The Chinese economy was suffering
and purchases of iPhones
in China fell sharply.
The higher price phone,
I think people felt
underwhelmed by the new features
and questioned whether it
was worth spending that much.
- [Narrator] In response,
the company slashed
it's quarterly revenue forecast
for the first time in over 15 years.
Since its peak, the company lost
more than $400 billion in market value.
2018 turned out to be Apple's
worst yearly stock performance
since the financial crisis.
And for some skeptics this fall from grace
seemed to confirm their
doubts that Tim Cook
would successfully lead the company.
Then in March, 2019,
Cook move to dramatically
expand his strategy,
the company started in 2017.
- Today, we're excited to extend
our services even further,
making them even more entertaining,
more useful and more informative.
- [Narrator] During a special event
in Cupertino, California,
the company announced the Apple
credit card, Apple TV plus,
and a number of new finance
gaming and new services.
- This was something
that had already been set
in motion before and that Tim Cook
had really been hammering
on for a couple of years
at that point.
And it was really part of an
effort to transform the company
from being focused on gadgets,
to being focused on
gadgets and the services
that attach themselves to those gadgets.
- [Narrator] Amid press around the event,
Apple stock price continued to rise.
The company's big bet on services
was starting to pay off.
- In the spring of 2019,
the US China trade war
was gathering momentum.
Donald Trump was threatening
and imposing new tariffs
and there was a great concern for Apple
that its iPhones and other gadgets
could get more expensive for US consumers
as a consequence of this.
- [Narrator] For years,
Trump has pressured Apple
to move more of its production to the US.
- And that was something
that really wasn't feasible
on a mass scale for Apple.
In fact, around this time,
they were planning to shift manufacturing
of the one product
that they were still making
in the US over to China
and that was their highest
end Mac desktop computer.
Cook was able to largely
navigate around the tariffs
and avoid having much damage
to Apple as a consequence.
- [Narrator] With key
products, such as iPhones
exempted from sanctions,
Apple stock continue to gain momentum.
But amid a surge of growth,
Apple's new focus on
services brought scrutiny
from federal regulators.
In the US the company
faced antitrust probes
related to its app store
where many of the services are based.
But this didn't seem to faze investors.
Over the course of the year.
Apple has bought back around $80 billion
worth of its own shares,
further juicing the stock price.
And by January 3rd, the
company's share price
had more than doubled
from the year before.
Apple's future looked promising
and then this happened.
- [Reporter] Chinese authorities
have traced a new deadly virus
back to this seafood market
in the city of Wuhan.
- The coronavirus has spread
to countries across the world.
- So via border restrictions
and global share market free falls,
attesting our politics,
economies and society.
- [Narrator] As the coronavirus pandemic
spread across the world,
Apple's manufacturing hubs in China
were hit, especially hard.
- Like most companies, Apples start
knows that have been in
February of this year,
the coronavirus was scaring investors
and Apple was probably more exposed to it
than most companies because
it had emanated from China.
Apple's contract manufacturers in China
had to close their factories for a time
as they dealt with the coronavirus impact.
- [Narrator] But Apple
stock quickly bounced back.
In the U S the federal reserve enacted
a colossal stimulus plan to
pump cash into the economy,
lifting the markets,
including stocks like Apple,
and as people's lives changed,
technology became even more essential.
- How is this whole working
from home thing going for you?
- During the pandemic
period, people were at home
had to work and their
children had to use computers
or tablets to be able to go to school.
People didn't have any other entertainment
other than what they could do at home.
So they were watching more TV programming
and streaming music and downloading apps.
All of that benefited Apple.
- [Narrator] On July 30th, Apple
released an earnings report
that highlighted an 11%
increase in revenue.
In April, we expected year over
year performance to worsen,
but we saw better than expected
demand in may and June.
We attribute this increase in demand
to several interactive causes,
including a strong iPhone SE launch,
continued economic stimulus.
- [Narrator] Following the news,
Apple shares continued to balloon
and on August 19th,
the company reached a
$2 trillion market cap
for the first time ever
becoming the most valuable
publicly traded company
in the world.
- At this point,
few people would bet
against Apple's ability
to execute, but at the same time,
there's no guarantee
that the stock is gonna keep
going up the way it has.
Apple faces a number of
significant challenges
on the regulatory front,
it's a subject of antitrust investigations
in the US and Europe,
it's also at war with
a number of companies
that are criticizing it
over its business practices
in the app store and elsewhere.
And it's more exposed than probably
any other American company
to the US China trade Wars.
- [Narrator] In the midst
of a volatile market,
Apple shares continue to see big swings.
(soft music)